at least two deaths are being blamed on
the scorching heat that blanketed much
of the country more than half a dozen
record high temperatures were broken or
tied in the eastern US on Saturday and
Sunday cooler temperatures are on the
way but it brings severe weather mega
oliver's in New Brunswick New Jersey
just outside of New York City mega I
understand a construction crane
collapsed during the violent weather
they're glad that's right the crane
crashed into this house Sunday evening
behind me in what neighbors describe is
a fast-moving storm but shortly after
that they said that it seemed as that
things calmed down
more storms are expected today following
a weekend of widespread extreme heat and
humidity that cut off power to more than
46,000 people in this region alone
severe thunderstorms breaking the
weakened sweltering heat wave are now
threatening millions from Tennessee to
New England with heavy rain and flash
flooding in Colorado and Ohio over the
weekend fast-moving water inundated
roads and backyards powerful winds
brought down trees from Minnesota to
Michigan damaging homes and causing
power outages impacting hundreds of
thousands and I came home to all this
and finding everybody safe thank
goodness during a storm in New Jersey
Heather Harris says she and her six
college roommates were away from their
home when this construction cranes
sliced through one of their bedrooms and
it happened probably 30 minutes after I
walked out it just it makes me feel like
I'm meant to be here about a thousand
miles south in Clearwater Florida city
officials say lightning injured eight
people on the beach one of them
critically he just might just instantly
just fell you could feel the like the
lightning strike through the ground on
the whole but with the dangerous weather
came cooler temperatures following more
than two days of stifling heat that felt
well into the triple digits in cities
like Memphis Raleigh and Boston
anyways before but this one just seemed
a little more out of the ordinary in New
York City in neighboring Westchester
County as many as 50,000 customers lost
electricity at one point Sunday evening
New York Governor Andrew Cuomo slammed
con Edison Sunday evening saying they
should have been better prepared for the
heat
Tony cooler weather can't come soon
enough Meg thank you very much